you
[Music]
it's an honor to have Thomas and home
here today from CMU Thomas is professor
of computer science at CMU he did his
PhD work this is I think I hear myself
booming in my ears but let's say it
louder so he did he did his PhD work at
University of Massachusetts at Amherst
and then did a brief tour at Washington
University and then onto professorship
at CMU among Thomas as many honors are
the itch cry computers and thought award
the inaugural ACM autonomous agents
research award the Allen Newell award
for research excellence at CMU the Sloan
fellowship the Carnegie Science Center
Award for Excellence
Adelman laureate chip and the NSF Career
Award and he's a fellow of ACM triple AI
and informs he's not really old enough
to hold any honorary degree degrees but
he holds an honorary Doctorate from the
University of Zurich had that happen
that's interesting they made a mistake
okay now if you watch the fire we just
did our fireside chat interview and if
you watch that this is an attractor we
talk about Thomas's famed history as a
windsurfing champion including winning
the the champion wind surfer ship in
Finland in 1986 I think it was but he's
like long history of being a sports
person and even playing under the emblem
of the the Finnish Air Force as a
windsurfing
that's why when you get out of service
you just wind surf your way through your
service and military whatever look at
Thomas when I see Thomas should show up
in a little sport coat like this and I
support code I think about a really
wonderful experience we had when Thomas
visited us it must been like 1999 or
something 98 98 and we went on Jack
breezes boat for dinner across the lake
and a beautiful day and about halfway
across the lake towards I think it was
Daniel's broiler it started absolutely
pouring out and we were kind of real
kind of adjusting windbreakers
but Thomas looked exactly like this you
know
ring-ring standing in front of the boat
you know and creamin looking quite
dapper but we all know that his clothes
was it was kind of a different shade
when he walked into the tent on for
dinner in this cooking with a sport coat
with that little story and then yet time
I spoke about super human AI for
strategic reasoning thanks a lot for
having me again it's great to be here I
seem to come here every few years can
you hear me okay in the back all right
great
so I'm gonna talk about super human AI
for strategic reasoning and mostly I'm
gonna talk about liberators and the
techniques that went into it which we
recently published in science with my
PhD student nan Brown and then in the
end I'm gonna talk about some of the
other things that are going on these
topics in my lab and applications and so
on all right and by the way I do ask
questions along the way so imperfect
information games are very unlike chess
or go where you just go you know exactly
what the state of the world is in
imperfect information games you don't
they're much more like negotiation or
poker or military settings or video
games and so forth so you all have
probably heard about alphago and alpha
zero and it's a great success story in a
very complex game and those techniques
can in principle apply to other perfect
information games and in fact they have
shown very good success for example in
chess and show again so on however they
don't apply to imperfect information
games at all
so imperfect information games you can
solve a sub game of the game tree based
on information in the sub game alone so
for example in chess
how you play the Sicilian defense is
completely independent how you should
play the Queen's Gambit this is not true
in imperfect information games and to
highlight this difference let me run
through an example and this is a small
example we call coin toss this also
shows the general representation how do
you represent imperfect information
games in a game independent way this is
called the extensive form which is a
standard representation in game theory
alright so how this works this example
and by the way this is a tiny
just for illustrative purposes the real
games are huge so we have three players
there's chance but I play a 1 and player
to chance really just act stochastically
not strategically and let's say in this
game chance just flips a coin heads or
tails 50/50 then player 1 can either
sell the coin or play and if player 1
place then player 2 gets a move gets to
guess which way the heads which way the
coin came out heads tails or player
two's going to just give up and say well
I don't know you win the payoffs are
shown from player ones perspective
players play to pay off it's just a
negative of that so if player 2 guesses
correctly player 1 gets -1 and if player
2 gets incorrectly or forfeits player 1
gets 1 okay now unlike perfect
information games there's this extra
structure here called the information
set oftentimes noted by this dashed line
or this purple ellipse that just
represents the fact that when player 2
has it's his turn to move he doesn't
know whether he's in left blue node or
the right blue node he has to infer that
information from player 1 strategy which
player 2 doesn't know okay so what is
rational play here well I've shown one
Nash equilibrium of the game here a Nash
equilibrium in general is a profile of
strategies one strategy for each player
where no player can improve their
expected utility by deviating to a
different strategy and what's a strategy
well it's just a mapping from
information sets to action probabilities
as that information set and an epsilon
Nash equilibrium is a strategy profile
where no player can improve more than
epsilon in expectation and not that the
Nash equilibrium the beliefs are derived
on the fly as we go down the game from
the equilibrium and observations so far
using Bayes rule so this is in some
since game theory is a generalization of
Bayesian reasoning and the
generalization of MVPs so this is really
a generalization of pom DPS into a multi
agent setting alright so one equilibrium
here is where player one cost 50/50 sell
and play by the way here I'm now
assuming that sell option is worth zero
so you can throw away the coin you don't
get anything for it and you don't have
to pay to get rid of it
and here 50/50 and player two gets his
heads half of the time and tails half
all the time all right this is not the
only equilibrium turns out that there's
an uncountable number of equilibria even
in this simple game okay now to make my
point I'm gonna argue that this sub game
here in this purple rectangle can't be
solved with information from the sub
game mode so if this were a complete
information game of perfect information
game this could be and most of the
algorithms like minimax search alpha
beta pruning and so on they are based on
the idea that you can solve the sub game
and do solve the sub game based on
information only in the sub game this
can't be done here so now first I'm
gonna say that the payoffs for selling
are 2 and minus 2 respectively in that
world what would play 1 do sell with
heads
yes and play with tails that's right
so when player 2 gets a move player 2
knows that it's tails so player 2 can
get tails it's a guest tails and win
whenever it was tails now if I flip the
payoffs in these triangles now you'd get
the opposite and player 2 should guess
heads whenever he gets a turn so that
just proves that how player 2 should
play depends on information that's
outside of sub game namely in these
triangles and here it's a simple example
those triangles could be arbitrarily big
and have transfer effects in the game
from very far away try to remember this
game because I'm going to use this as a
running example later
any questions from the game itself okay
so when we tackle imperfect information
games we can't use techniques for
perfect information games we developed
application independent techniques so
these are not poker techniques and also
they're algorithmically creating the
strategies so we're not programming the
strategies by hand or anything like that
challenges here well uncertainty about
what others and chance will do but more
importantly uncertainty about what
others and chance have already done that
gives me hidden state and then I have to
think about what do my actions signal to
my opponents about my private
information and what my opponent's
actions signal to me about the
opponent's private information the
really cool thing here is that we don't
have to assume a meaning for the signals
that automatically falls out of the
classic solution concepts in game theory
like Nash equilibrium and it's
refinements so the real work here is to
marry those classical solution concepts
with algorithms so we can compute
something that's near a Nash equilibrium
so poker itself that has been a
recognized challenge problem in game
theory O'War and AI for decades and if
you actually go back to John Nash's PhD
thesis which actually was very short and
you should where he introduced Nash
equilibrium which really transformed all
of economics and many other sciences the
one and only example there was poker so
but that was a poker game called cool
poker which has three cards in the dick
and only one card in each of the two
players hands so it's a very small form
of poker so small that you can actually
solve it by hand paper and pen and then
there's been steady progress in poker
but really there's been tremendous
explosion in work on using poker as a
benchmark over the last fourteen years
and I'm hundreds of papers I'm not going
to try to do a full literature review
I'm going to mainstream kind of three
highlights here one is rod I
holdin this is a game that has three
billion nodes in the game tree and we
were able to solve it exactly in 2005 so
this was about four or five orders of
magnitude bigger than what had been
solved before and the key idea here was
lossless abstraction so you can actually
algorithmically walk through the game
tree gets rid ix rid of 99% of it
roughly and you get a game which you
solve and then you get an exact answer
to the original game so in some sense
there are so many weird isomorphisms
in these games that you can get rid of
all of them and still get an exact
solution although you're solving a game
that's only 1/100 of the size and then
we'll see plexus LP solver
in 25 days on a small supercomputer we
were able to solve that abstracted game
to get an answer then the annual
computer poker competition started in
2006 where different teams around the
world compete on the same benchmarks and
you can measure progress year to year
and group to group and that has really
fueled progress in the field because
most of the top teams have been
publishing their results and building on
each other's work then Limit Texas
Hold'em was near optimal is solved by
bowling at all in 2015 that's another
science paper and that's a game that has
after lossless abstraction ten to the
thirteen information sets ten to the
thirteen decision points and this this
was the heads up variant which is
two-player and limit means that whenever
it's you're trying to move if you bet
there's a fixed amount you can bet
there's no choice as to how much you bet
and that means that the branching factor
is two or three depending on the
situation now heads up No Limit Texas
Hold'em is a whole other animal this has
become the main benchmark and challenge
problem in AI for imperfect information
game solving it has teamed ^ 161
different situations the player can
phase information sets and for this
audience I probably don't need to
explain what that number means
but it's more than the number of atoms
in the universe and even if you had a
whole other universe for every atom in
the universe and counted those it's more
than that so you're not about to store
this anywhere and you're not about to
traverse this game tree even once so you
need some totally different techniques
this is mostly played on the internet
but it's also played on TV and in the
top poker movies many people consider
this a purist form of Poker because it's
really two-player so there are no third
players or fourth players that are going
to mess it up it's really a might better
or is max better just like chess and no
prior AI has been in top humans at this
game alright so how many of you actually
know this game okay so not everybody so
I'm gonna walk through this a little bit
to the extent you need to know how the
rules work just on one slide so first
chance deals two cards in private to
each player both players then there's a
round of betting then chance deals three
shared cards face up on the table then
there's another round of betting then
chance deals one shared card face up on
the table then this round of betting
then then there's a fourth round will
chance to use one more shared card on
the table and a round of betting all
right so at this point what we have the
players holding two cards in private and
five public cards on the table what you
try to do is make the best five-card
hand out of those seven cards and
whoever has the better five-card hand
wins the whole pot the hard part is the
betting so you have to decide whether to
bet or not and if the opponent has bet
whether to call fold or bet even more
which is called raising if somebody
falls they lose the pot right there and
if only if both players come all the way
to the end
do you actually compare the hands so
that's how it works
and when I say 10 to the 161 I mean one
play of the game
just a short on the slide so when we
play let's say 120,000
petitions it's not counting the
repetitions just one handle poker is 10
to the 161 any questions so far yeah ah
well let me answer that at the end if
that's still unclear okay so in January
2017 I organized this brains versus AI
rematch and I'm calling it a rematch
because I had organized a similar match
in April 2015 where we took on four of
the top humans at this game and we
couldn't beat them it's very close
statistically speaking it was actually
statistically insignificant so a
statistical tie but we couldn't beat
them at they ended up ahead so now we
had this new AI called the Brazos
it's a Latin stands for balanced for
Nash equilibrium and powerful for its
forceful playstyle and that took a while
to figure out that Latin name anyway so
we played against four of the best heads
up Knoll in Texas Hold'em specialist
pros so these are professionals not just
at poker but at this particular form of
Poker and it's very important because
you know these guys are way stronger
than the typical general TV pros that
you might see at this particular kind of
poker which is two-player we played one
hundred and twenty thousand hands over
20 days in January 2017 so each one of
them played 30,000 hands and it's
important that you play a lot of hands
for two reasons one you don't want this
to be decided by luck you want it to be
statistically significant and in 2015 we
played 80,000 hands and it was not
enough to get 95% statistical
significance which is the threshold we
use in the annual computer poker
competition so now my worry was that if
we were a little bit behind or even a
lot behind the humans back then now
humans had probably progressed a little
bit but hopefully we had progressed more
so it should have been even closer so I
felt that we would need even more hands
to get statistical significance and it
would have been kind of a shame to have
another event where we can't really
declare a winner the other reason is
that you want to give the humans the
best possible chance to find weaknesses
in the AI and exploit those weaknesses
so like you may have heard about the
dota2 boats which are able to beat top
humans for a while and then when humans
get to play with them more even average
humans can beat them so that though you
want to make sure this is not just some
sort of a transient that for a while you
can beat them when they don't really
know your holes I'll come back to that
they got to choose all of the parameters
I actually have a whole slide we can
talk about that in the Q&A part but they
chose 20 days we said okay how many days
do you want to play over this is this
was a given but everything else they
chose how many days when to take breaks
break days hours of the day every day
got to choose even dynamically like on
one day they said all mine one of our
players feels really tired maybe they're
getting a cold
let them not play so I said okay on this
afternoon we don't play and so on so
that what it ended up being on average
maybe excluding breaks maybe about eight
hours a day with breaks maybe 10 hours a
day which is way less than what they
normally play so sometimes these guys
play like three hour three days straight
and we did a conservative experiment
design where we let them pick almost all
over the parameters of the tournament so
that we wouldn't get too into kind of a
COS power of like whining thing at the
end in case we would win I have all
slide on all those parameters if you're
interested in that like how they are
works first I'll talk about the match
and then I'll talk about how that here
would be cute questions I cover
yes most of which I'm skipping so that
it's great to take questions if you
don't have to answer them so this is
what it looks like so here we have my
PhD student norm some of the casino
personnel here's our Dean looking very
worried he told me up front that if you
don't win this time you're fired I hope
he was joking I didn't want to test him
and here's Jason less one of the pros
and here's Daniel Macaulay one of the
pros but you see only two over the pros
here where are the other two so this is
the casino floor these guys are playing
public in public the other two are
playing in a private isolation chamber
on the second floor where for your
question we're actually doing duplicate
matches so whatever hand danielle gets
against the AI he's paired human in that
match the AI gets that against the human
so neither that he must know the AI can
systematically get lucky because they're
essentially getting the same hands and
of course you have to keep them in
isolation otherwise they could tell each
other what hands are coming next and all
right so this is we're having some fun
with Jason this is what it looks like
they actually chose to play two tables
at once so a left table right table and
these are different hands and they can
choose to play like one one one one or
play all of the hands of Accession here
and then here but they like to do this
because they're used to playing multi
table and they can then let their brains
to on some of the tough questions on one
table while making progress on the other
table so this is one of the parameters
that they selected here you have a chat
window which they could choose
individually whether to keep on or not
so whether the audience could actually
interact with them and Jason loved it he
felt that he plays best when the
audience is cheering him on and for
mankind and some some of the other other
humans felt that no no I'm gonna turn it
off I want to just focus and I'm best
when I'm just focus
questions and you time to share they go
back and forth yeah is there it is there
I go responsiveness people have really
actually stew for a while like you know
like depends on the hands so most times
are very easy to play so most times they
just know how to play optimally very
quickly and then there are some
difficult times where they take more
time we had no time limit for the humans
so actually the timing was interesting
we got a lot of angry comments on the
chat saying oh the board thinks too long
well turns out that on average the
humans thought twenty seconds the what
they thought thirteen so the bot was
actually playing faster than the humans
but it's thinking behavior was very
different so first of all the AI didn't
think at all in the first two backing
rounds it's basically using a local
table and then it would tank it will
stop to think for 30 or 45 seconds in
the beginning of the third betting round
which is a very unusual timing for the
hema so they kind of got disoriented
with that and I mean the audience the
other thing is that humans generally
think harder when there's a lot at stake
so if there's a lot of money in the pot
the she must think harder then if
there's a little bit of money the AI
does the exact opposite because the less
money there is in the pot the more
re-raise possibilities there are and the
bigger the game tree after that is so
the AI would actually think the longest
when there was the least at stake which
was weird for do you think these guys
are closer to those assumptions and what
happens if good good good so what if the
opponent isn't rational well there's a
whole other line of work that has been
done in the field and which we've
contributed also called opponent
exploitation
trying to exploit weaknesses in the
opponent but I'm going to talk about why
I decided not to turn those things on
here because this Nash equilibrium
approach is safe if the opponent does
something else not rational it can
actually only help me because it's a
zero-sum game so so we wanted to build
an unbeatable AI we didn't necessarily
want to exploit the humans by the
biggest possible amount well know what
going so many questions let let me
postpone and because we have a lot to
cover okay so up before we go to the
bottom line there so people really
believe in people so the international
betting sites put Isis support to one or
five to one underdog on the morning of
the event so we were walking into this
as a huge underdog but what happened is
this Lee brothers beat the top humans in
this again by a lot statistical
significance ninety nine point nine to
eight percent or a p-value of 0.0002
or if you like Finance for Sigma it's a
very clear victory so my worry that ok
maybe one hundred and twenty thousand
hands wouldn't be enough was totally
unfounded we had just blown past the
best humans in the eighteen months
between the previous match and this
match the wind rate was one hundred and
forty seven million plants per game or
fourteen point seven big points per head
per hundred if you're a poker player
each of the humans individually also
lost to Lee brothers and this was kind
of a big deal so now before we go to the
techniques then I got the email from
China saying it okay well that was
fantastic now we're in April 2017 that
was fantastic
I want you to come and do the same thing
in China and I'm like well there's no
value to it we've already beaten the
best humans in the world so there's no
scientific values so I don't I don't
really think so and they said he said
well actually you know he was actually
one of our PhD graduates a very famous
Chinese PhD career
from the late 80s and he said well in
China people don't know that CMU was so
great in AI they've heard of Stanford
and Harvard but not so much seem you so
why don't you do this is going to be
good for CMU and I said okay we'll do it
as an exhibition not the scientific
experiment per se we'll do an exhibition
because they didn't want to play as long
and my worry is that if we play some
small number of hands it's a coin flip
and that would be not good so we played
only 36,000 hands against six Chinese
poker players by the way the brand that
we used was not Libra today we used link
for dashi which was a name given to Rai
by the Chinese team I think it means
called poker master and these included
China's one and only World Series of
Poker bracelet winner and these people
had expertise in computer science and
machine learning as well not just poker
and when we got there we kind of walked
into a trap in that they had somehow
scraped all of the hand history of the
AIC so they had a hundred and twenty
thousand hands of sample of how we play
we didn't know this in advance wasn't
really explicitly forbidden but but
anyway so now we're facing a very
different kind of opponent and by the
way so when I got there it is three
story building just for this event
there's this big media studio with
professional poker commentators on one
floor there's actually bent on another
floor and then this is one bottom floor
where this is an elevator shaft inner
and a door so at one point I decided I'm
gonna peek in there and guess what I saw
there a long table of analysts on their
computers doing real-time analysis of
the play and giving the humans advice
that wasn't disallowed either but I mean
this is what we were facing all right so
now Len poo dashi won by 220 milli big
points per game so even more than we had
won in January and it also won each of
the nine sessions and beat each of the
humans individually so what does this
say well first of all it says that the
players we played in January were really
good in that they played better even
without any background history on how we
play but the other thing is really more
fundamental it's really showing the
power of game theory as opposed to say
reinforcement learning in that the game
theory approach is thinking about all
possible strategies of the opponent so
it doesn't matter that they know our
strategy we're basically not exactly
nask but approximately Nash but an exact
Nash equilibrium would be unbeatable
even if they know exactly our strategy
and this is unlike what has been seen in
RL approaches like forego and dota 2 so
if you've seen the go dog documentary
even the European champion who wasn't
really the best in the world was able to
beat the alphago after some practice
with it and in dota 2 even average
humans can beat it once they get some
practice with it so this is a bit lesson
I think all right then maybe maybe
there's something more general in this
as well to go and limb a little bit
maybe for adversarial machine learning
maybe there should be some more games
already thinking and and so on I know
there's some initial connections already
alright so how does Li blotters work
well the high-level point is probably
correct techniques so you won't see for
example deep learning here these are all
theoretically correct techniques we were
running on bridges which is the newest
supercomputer at the Pittsburgh
supercomputing Center we were running on
CPUs back then we also have GPU codes
now and in the end time allowing I'll
talk about something that can be done on
one server which is not quite as good
but the newer newer technique all right
so the architecture has really three
main pieces one is the pre computation
over over what we call a blueprint
strategy for the whole game
it takes on as input the rules of that
game runs an abstraction algorithm and
then runs an approximate equilibrium
finding algorithm on the abstract game
to come up with a blueprint strategy for
both players for the whole game
then there's a sub game solver which
takes the blueprint and solves the sub
game that's actually reached to come up
with a finer grained strategy in a finer
grained abstraction and now you might
say wait wait a second Thomas you just
told me in the beginning that this is
impossible and now you're telling us
that you're doing it so what gives I'm
gonna tell you how this is actually
possible the short answer is that the
blueprint gives enough context that you
can isolate the sub games in there
enough that that you can get probably
correct techniques even in this
imperfect information pick games and
then there's a self-improvement module
and notice that this is not the typical
way of using machine learning in in
games which is opponent exploitation
instead I thought that that would be
very risky here because we're playing
against the best humans they don't have
very big holes to exploit and their
world leading experts at counter
exploitation so let's not use those
opponent exploitation techniques instead
we're doing a new kind of thing here
which is that we are letting the humans
actions tell us where the humans think
that we have holes and then overnight we
are fixing those holes to play even more
game theoretically in those spots so
that that's not in the sense of the
patches are then universal they apply
against all here all opponents and this
is not a big data story you could argue
whether this is some machine learning
story at all but if you think about the
first two modules there's no data it's a
zero data story you're just taking on
the rules of the game
that's input and here there's minimal
machine learning as I'll show you so to
put this in perspective that's a boxing
analog so if it's like shadow boxing
against a mirror and then jumping in the
ring with Mike Tyson to see what happens
all right so now let's go through these
in order so the abstraction works as
follows we have the rules of the game
the game tree is too big to represent so
we have the rules in compact form we run
an abstraction algorithm we get an
abstracted game about 10 to the 14 or 10
to the 13 then we run a new equilibrium
finding algorithm to come up with an
epsilon equilibrium for the abstracted
game this is about 50 terabytes of
probabilities and then you unobstructed
to answer to play the blueprint in the
original game the abstraction has two
kinds of abstraction one is chance
abstraction and the other is abstracting
the player's actions tranzact
abstraction in poker is abstracting the
cards will use the same algorithm that
we used in titanium 8 which had won the
annual or baby version of which one
Daniel poker competition in 2016 but now
in a much finer abstraction and in
particular for the first two betting
rounds we had no obstruction so full
understanding of the cards and then in
the latter two Rob betting rounds
there's a obstruction but by the time we
get there the in-game solver kicks in
which doesn't have abstraction so now we
never play with card abstraction at any
point in the game abstracting the
player's actions which is bed sizes in
the case of poker this is largely based
on what top humans on top a is from the
past have done but we also added radical
bed sizes like Big O leans tiny 10% bits
why well we just want to see whether it
would ever play those with probability
that's greater than 0
might as well and then we have this
first convergent algorithm for finding
optimal bed size combinations but it's
not very scalable so we were using that
only for the first two bed sizes so we
were optimizing the size of the first
two bed sizes algorithmically now what's
a new equilibrium planning algorithm
well it's an improvement on Monte Carlo
counterfactual regret minimization now
I'll unpack what that means some of you
may already know that regret
minimization is this technique
where you are based on your history
you're trying to minimize average regret
and counterfactual means that you don't
do it in the space of strategies but you
do it at every information set
separately and this you have to be
careful how to glue those together and
Monte Carlo means that you're sampling
you're not traversing the whole game
tree now the new thing is that you start
visiting less open paths where our own
actions don't look promising
so we're our own actions have very high
negative regret currently this gives you
a speed-up because you're visiting less
offer in the bad pass so we can solve
larger abstractions also in imperfect
Oracle abstractions which is a state of
the art abstraction you have this issue
that many different paths lay to the
same abstract state in the future and
now some of those paths will effectively
get discounted away with this technique
so there's less fighting in those
abstract States as to what you should do
because four different paths how you got
there you might want to do different
things so you get actually better
solution quality as well not just better
speed alright so now let's talk about
sub game solving and this is maybe the
most novel part of the architecture this
is where we take the blueprint strategy
and we compute a refined strategy in a
finer grained abstraction in the sub
game that's used
that's reached during play and if you
think about the timing of this think
about this being weeks or months of
computation in advance of the match
these like 30 or 40 seconds of
computation during the hand and this is
an overnight process on let's say 200
servers ok and now I'm going to jump
into a little bit of detail here so if
you don't follow it's ok as the after 5
or 10 minutes we'll get back to the high
level and I'm gonna actually do a
transformational analogy through the
history of in game solving in imperfect
information games because there have
only been so few papers I can actually
go
the whole thing so new ideas in the sub
games Oliver probably safe sub game
solving taking to account opponents
mistakes in the hand so far so let's
talk about that first and there I'm
gonna do the analogy so the first
techniques for sub game solving in
imperfect information games were unsafe
that's what we call them nowadays
we didn't call it back then so let's say
that this is the blueprint strategy in
this example coin toss game it's not an
exact equilibrium or equilibrium finder
didn't give us an exact answers you can
see it here we're 50/50 here we water
three quarters here there's more heads
guessing and tails guessing and there's
some forfeiting calling on so you can
see that that's not really the best
strategy but it's a decent strategy then
what we're trying to do we're trying to
compute a better strategy for liberators
as player 2 and here I'm going to show
all of these techniques in the same
abstraction just for simplicity in
reality we would want to change the
abstraction so that we have a finer
grained game tree here under that player
2 information set so the original idea
of unsafe sub game solving is a we just
use Bayes rule we assume a player 1
place according to these probabilities
from the blueprint so then we get the
probabilities here and here using Bayes
rule and if you compute the best
strategy to that you see that player 2
would always get hit okay and that's a
fine strategy if player 1 indeed sticks
to that strategy up there but of course
highly exploitable in that player one
could play so that that's always a
better target okay so no theoretical
guarantees but this just well in
practice in some domains and it seems
that in bigger domains these type of
problems are less prevalent or at least
less pronounced then the first safe sub
game solving technique was called resold
refinement by virtue tau
here is a little bit of a mind-bending
thing in that we are allowing the
opponent to make an action which is a
selection of abstractions so here we
have again the blueprint strategy in
purple and we can look at what's the
expected value of playing in here given
player to strategy at zero and here the
expected value of playing is half so now
I'm going to construct this gadget game
where I'm going to compute the player to
strategy for the sub game as follows I'm
gonna give player one the choice of
entering the original abstraction and
taking this expected value and this
expected value or I'm allowing player
one to enter the sub game which
typically would be in a finer grained
abstraction so again a little bit of
mind-bending thing now there's an action
that we allow the opponent to take which
is not a real world action it's a
selection between abstractions all right
now player one can choose between
entering the sub game or taking the
expected value according to the
blueprint of the sub game what we want
to make sure here in the gadget game is
that the opponent's expected value of
entering the sub game is no higher than
in the blueprint if we can guarantee
that then the strategy is probably no
worse than the blueprint strategy and in
particular if the blueprint was Nash
this is still Nash any questions on that
idea okay now trust me here's what will
come out or one of the things that could
come out of your solver these purple
numbers and that you can see that
they're the same numbers as here so it
might actually come up with the same
strategy as a blueprint so what have we
actually accomplished and then it might
miss obvious opportunities for
improvement for example never forfeiting
we know kind of intuitive let forfeiting
is a bad idea you might as well make a
guess because it's free so we know that
this forfeiting is a mistake and it's
still it still pair with positive
probability
okay so the next improvement to that was
called max margin refinement buy more of
chiquita here we have again the same
idea choice of abstraction so this is
the same so far it's similar to resolve
but punishes player1 as much as possible
for choosing entering rather than out so
we define a margin for every type that
the opponent might have so in auctions
it would be valuation types here it's
heads or tails so for example the margin
for heads is expected value of the
alternative of heads minus the expected
value of entering under heads and we
solve this by maximizing the minimum
margin this is in contrast to the
previous slide where we simply attend to
make all of the margins non-negative
yeah we like enter is the here to enter
in the sell game as opposed to choosing
the blueprint but what do you do after
you enter do you get a reward
upon entering do you have to go all the
way to the leaf of the tree to do do you
let the opponent user we are trying to
compute a strategy for player two here
and and in this model we are well let me
show you that so you would get five days
here three days here zero here so
there's no forfeiting anymore and the
expected value would be minus quarter
here and a quarter here and if you look
at the margins it's actually balancing
the margin so the margin here is the
same as the margin here does it make
sense now no I still don't understand
what this interim because entering is a
player one right entering is a player
one move it that is the choice of that
distraction player one can take the
alternative here from the original
blueprint obstruction or enter the into
this new sub game I see you're just
trying to maximize if he were to choose
enter we are trying to maximize how much
he would lose by going enter instead of
out yes okay yeah and here how much he
would lose is a quarter on here and a
quarter here
this kind of like I don't want to play
the game anymore let's stop here no no
it's not that it's not that I want to
stop here it's I want to play according
to our original abstraction oh that
makes muscles
let me postpone them we're running a
little late here okay so the new East
End
well the problem here is that while we
focus and reduce in player one's
expected value for heads - - quarters
player one can actually just sell for
half in the head situation so this is
still somehow missing something and the
newest idea is what we call reach max
margin refinement and now we're solving
a single sub game first we'll talk about
multiple in a second let's focus on this
yellow part here I'm not going to show
you the gadget game for but here somehow
if player 1 plays here player 1 is
making a mistake of half right player 1
is giving us a gift of half so in the
gadget game we can increase the
alternative pay of following heads by
half because choosing play would still
be a mistake for player 1 there so we
can afford to give half of gift half
which is the size of the gift back and
it would still be a mistake or half
minus Epsilon
thus the gadget games Oliver focuses on
reducing player ones expected value for
other types she may have so that's the
only extra thing over the previous slide
is that we're keeping track of these
gifts and we can afford for some types
to give back something and those are
exactly the types where the gift was
positive for others it was zero and we
can't afford to give back anything so
this gives us in a way a bigger polytope
to optimize strategies over in a safe
way alright so now to flies in the
ointment and this is kind of a side deal
here but one is that if multiple sub
games are refined the off path expected
values might not remain constant so here
let's say that we have the same gift of
half here now we can
if we change take the gift here say that
that's one this is half now we can't
also take all we can take the gift here
but we can't take the gift on both sides
on different sub game themselves in
different hands because now we've made
ourselves exploitable so we know
solution to this is we split the gifts
among the sub games by the probability
that the sub game is reached so for
example here if this is half half
we take half of the gift on this side
and half of the gift on this side there
are other ways that are safe as well but
you can't count the full gift on all
sides because now you would no longer be
safe other applying ointment is that the
gifts might not be as large as we
thought because the sub games they come
from will be improved so let's say here
we thought of gift is half here but
because we're going to improve this sub
game the actual gift is only a quarter
and you can substitute the lower bound
on the gift and it can even be an
estimate in practice all right off two
reactions are nested sub game solving
now this is going to be kind of
mind-bending that that can actually
change the abstraction on-the-fly and
still have Nash equilibrium guarantees
so normally when the branching factor is
large in games like in No Limit Texas
Hold'em you actually just put some of
the actions into the model we call this
action abstraction and then we always
can play into the abstraction because we
control our actions but the opponent
might play something that's not in our
model so let's say the opponent plays at
green action then we pretend that they
actually played the black catch and this
is called the reverse mapping or action
mapping how do we map these green
actions back into the abstraction and
there's a whole literature how to do do
that the newest and latest and greatest
on that strand is that it's guys 13
paper and we'll benchmark against that
now we want to get rid of that entirely
so what we do is that we are going to
solve a sub game in real time including
the oft reaction that opponent actually
took
so now we're adding branches to our
action abstraction
or a game model on the fly and we'd
still like to be able to prove
equilibrium properties so here's what
what it would look like so let's say it
player one can take three actions with
expected values XY and Z but instead
that's in our head but in reality they
do something else so we actually
construct this same kind of idea that
player one the opponent can actually
choose between abstractions either in
the original game where he gets a
maximum of XY and Z the best of the
original actions or this new action
which is generated on the fly - might be
exactly the action of top on it actually
took all right so properties of this
this actually works even with hidden
actions by chance which you don't see in
poker so now let me define delta there
is not an assumption it's a definition
of Delta so let Delta be such that there
exists a Nash equilibrium where each out
payoff for player one is within Delta of
the Nash equilibrium expected value at
that point for player one so that's
basically saying well let me leave it at
that then I'll reach max margin subway
and solving technique yields a to Delta
minimax strategy for player two for the
full game so this means that we can
actually change our abstraction
on-the-fly and we're still almost
optimal and how close to optimal we are
is how off our blueprint was from Nash
if it was an exact Nash we're still
exact Nash now there's another version
of this which talks about it in a
different way where if player once alt
payoffs are computed from a best
response in the full game to play your
tooth blueprint then the strategy ombré
are to reach max margin sub game solving
technique has no greater regret and play
for player two in the full game than
players two blueprint strategy saying it
okay this is not gonna make the
blueprint may make the strategy worse
than what it was and notice that there's
no notion of Delta here however badiya
blueprint was it's not gonna get worse
nested this can actually be reapplied
for every subsequent opponent of three
action as well so we don't have to just
do it once we can apply the same over
and over in the hand as we get deeper
and deeper into the game and theorem one
prime is that now that you're not off by
two Delta - Delta x number of
reapplications within one playthrough so
if you applying these three times it's
six Delta and theorem two prime for this
setting well it's the same as two so
you're not gonna make the blueprint
worse all right experiments on
medium-sized games this is not Texas
Hold'em because there you can't compute
the best response to evaluate how
exploitable you are this is a
medium-sized poker game our best reach
sub game solving technique there's
actually multiple variations has three
times less exploitability than the best
prior safe sub game called solving
technique and the nested reach sub game
solving is twelve times less exploitable
and the best action mapping technique so
indeed this idea of action mapping is
dominated by this nested reach sub game
soul okay also the sub game solving
starts much earlier typically well
typically help in two years by then only
it had been on the last betting round
now we're actually starting it already
on the third betting round there's no
code abstraction in the sub game because
we have these more scalable sub game
solving techniques and we can actually
change our action abstraction between
hands now that we're solving our sub
games on new anyway we might as well
change our action abstraction a little
bit because the value of the game is not
very sensitive to the action abstraction
but the strategy is quite sensitive to
it this keeps our opponents on the on
their toes all the time because they're
facing a different action abstraction
all the time and they have to think
through it every time okay so now if
you're a poker player you know that this
type of sub game solving would show up
in what's known as blockers how do you
think about blocker cards and if you
don't know poker don't worry about it
I'm going to play a video about this the
guy who's been interviewed is Daniel
McCauley he
is one of the two or the three people in
the world who was an open promise that
they will play anybody in the world at
this game and and know this by the pay
attention to what he says when he is
called for an example he has just played
thirty thousand kinds of poker and he's
been asked to recall an example of a
particular kind and he just really
recalls it just like that you know in
contrast to the first challenge there
was a lot of hands the first time around
where you know the bottom really just
went off I've seen way less of that so
what are your thoughts how good is the
bottom it's pretty good I mean we're on
losing so if I consider myself pretty
good then it must it must be pretty good
and but doesn't it's not really any
punting like I think it uses blockers
Raylan the bluff sports like I've not
really picked up on anything this too
obvious one way or the other
so I'm I'm genuinely impressed yes
pretty good oh okay maybe it's a next
next one where we see yeah it's a later
video where we talk see the example all
right so let's talk about the last
module the self improver so again I
mentioned that we are not going to try
to do opponent exploitation here
although there are algorithms for it but
it would be in my opinion it would have
been too risky so we didn't do it we
cannot instead to a different kind of
idea that I think we're real first to do
where we let the opponent's actions tell
us where the opponents think they've
found holes in our strategy and then
we're going to fix those holes overnight
to play more game theoretically in those
spots all right so here's a simple
example let's say Lee brothers most
first than the opponent these are action
abstraction in the blueprint and let's
say that opponent has actually played
also some other actions out of the
obstruction so those green actions now
we're going to automatically prioritize
which of those are the biggest holes and
it has to do with how close you are to
that prototypical actions the blue ones
and how often they're played the closer
you are the less of a problem it is and
the more often it's played the bigger
the problem it is so let's say that this
is the worst problem we call this a top
one hole
now we're going to generate a course
record abstraction for that part so we
can solve it overnight instead of months
and we're going to put a default action
one of the already existing blue actions
in there even in an even coarser
abstraction so that we don't end up
assuming that the opponent plays this
with all possible cards that he might be
here with then we're going to freeze
this part of the blueprint strategy and
we're going to recompute this for
epsilon equilibrium using the same
algorithm overnight and then we're gonna
throw this one away and this gives us a
strategy for new branch of the game tree
that wasn't there all right and we do
this for the top Kay holes depending on
how big your game is and how much
supercomputing you have you can do more
or less holes we typically try to do two
or three holes a night and then in the
morning we had a test against our prior
AI is to see whether the hole had been
sufficiently solved and if so we would
put it in the execution engine and if
not then not so now let's talk and let's
see what the humans say about the holes
and and the self fixing of the holes the
energy level is super high the first few
days you know we start up in the hole
can't expect it as we're figuring out
what's going on and then we climbed all
the way back to basically nearly even
and we are like you know we're in this
we have a chance and we had like key
strategy ideas key things we were
pushing against the AI and then I I
guess the wheels kind of just came off
the wagon and it wasn't that our play
fell apart in my opinion I think we've
really seen a clear improvement in the
AI strategy day to day to day okay and
let's see what fema Cho has to say about
it the bot plays an incredible it the
first two or three nights I severely
underestimated its ability I really
thought that we were just going to find
a couple simple weeks I'm just hammer
away at it and
yeah you know easy 20 20 days but it's
been a complete opposite every time we
find something it seems to adjust the
next day and we have to continue to look
for leaks but eventually that we just
were not able to buy any okay head to
head strength of the top a ice so higher
on the slide is stronger here are ours
on the left others on the right there
are many other areas these are just
showing the top ones I guess the bottom
line here is that usually you see an
improvement or maybe 10 or 20 milli big
boy sperm game per year and here we saw
in 18 months we saw 63 million plans
which is a big improvement
mostly driven by the sub game solving it
didn't even measure the contribution of
the last component another kind of
interesting thing is that this modicum a
I which is our newest AI which is not
the strongest Lee brothers this was
actually built just on a wreck one
server so this is not a supercomputing
deal here at all so observations about
Lee brothers is play well strengths it
plays very in an unusual way so if
you're looking for heterogeneity is
heterogeneity in a is for games this is
what you it's a it's better to actually
have at least one of the things be
something that's generated from scratch
rather than copying different humans
because humans always play in a kind of
a subspace of the game a strategy space
small bets and huge bets and huge olan's
plays a totally different kind of poker
in and humans have been used to multiple
bet sizes in any one situation he must
typically play one or at most two it
plays these actions called limping and
donk betting which poker books
universally say are bad we do them
regularly not all the time but we do
them with good probability in all of the
AIS for example that we've generated
limping happens with a to top 12% so
that suggests that you know it's not
really a bad action perfect balance
well Nash will be perfect of course
we're not exactly asked so but that's
what the humans call it mixed strategy
probability distributions of a player's
hands not just range based thinking
which is
the supports of the distributions as
many pros do nowadays near-perfect sub
gameplay great use of blockers different
bed sizings used in different sub games
weaknesses well there's no opponent
exploitation but that's by choice in
that we wanted to make something as very
hard to beat rather than something that
would exploit weak players by the
biggest possible amount now over the
1314 years up to this point that I had
been working on a poker I hadn't been a
poker player plays by the way but I
started to love the game over that time
and then when we finally got to this
point I started worrying it I'm not
going to ruin the game there's many ways
to ruin a game and and one of them would
be to say it okay here's an optimal way
of playing and it's boring so my worry
was that we're going to find some sort
of strategy that chisels a little bit of
value here and there and it's kind of
boring and let's see what Don Kim he's
probably the number one player in the
world currently has to say about that is
safe play equilibrium play in other
words he's at the middle boring and I
apologize there's some swearing in this
video you know a lot of people asked me
to ask you guys is does the bottom Bluff
Bob Bluff sure gangster s
can you give me an example of a maybe a
crazy bot Bluff that we wouldn't have
seen from a person today he flatted a
four bet with five three of clubs and
the fall came king queen Jack with two
hearts check check icon a flush check
check gotta set a trap five River he
bets I really small fifty bet chance
that's that's a pretty gangster he's
view bang stuff but he's not messing
around
and it's like manly possibly thank best
yes it's payback stuff yeah yeah I think
for for humans in a lot of those
situations when it gets into weird lines
like you know for bet pot check check
check check and then all of a sudden
there's you know Bebe's 3bet I think a
lot of players they kind of are a little
too afraid to maybe Bluff I think we can
pretty safely say that's not the case
here yeah it's like maybe a little
better faith and also just like
everyone's ranges so weird it's very
hard to choose by chance
whereas I can just like go that's
percentage of this hand or less
percentage of that hand so okay and
every situation you have yours question
like walk in the buffer and then you it
doesn't really matter all right
it always has blows okay so I guess that
answers you're bluffing question to an
extent at least so now let me pop up
back to the higher level or some current
research on this topic in my lab and I
mean this topic as in game solving we're
doing other things like kidney exchange
advertising markets and things like that
as well but now I'll just focus on this
so one is lossy abstraction algorithms
with bounds so the abstraction
algorithms that are currently used in
practice they don't have bounds on how
much you lose unless the loss less once
but they don't abstract enough the
remaining game is still too big to solve
so now we have these lossy abstraction
algorithms with bounds and after we
started developing those I realized that
they're not really about just
abstraction for computational speed
they're also the same theory applies to
looking at modeling so all modeling is
abstraction and now this is talking
about if we can measure the difference
between reality about the difference
between reality and our model then we
can for the first time say that our game
theoretic strategies have some bound on
how good they are for the real world
which is kind of astonishing in that
we've been doing
Ouisa game theorists have been doing
game theory for many many decades yet
there has been no discussion of how the
answers have come out of models actually
how good are they for reality now to do
still is we need to unify our best
practical abstraction algorithms with
the theory so the theoretical algorithms
are not the same as the practically best
ones currently simultaneous abstraction
and equilibrium finding so I showed you
this water flow of fall which is a
traditional way of doing it abstract
first then solve here we are actually
allowing the equilibrium finder to tell
what straits are similar in their
strategies and therefore maybe they
shouldn't be abstracted and and and
similarly so there's an iteration
between abstraction and equilibrium
finding and the key then is how do you
actually warm start the equilibrium
finder once you've changed our
abstraction otherwise it's way too slow
so we first had warm starting algorithms
that relied on a particular kind of
equilibrium finding algorithm and now we
can do general warm starts 4cf our
algorithms so no matter where the worm's
initial strategies came from from a
different equilibrium finder from human
intuition whatever we can now start c FR
with those so you don't have to start
from scratch c FR is the counterfactual
regret minimization then new fastest
algorithm for the CF r family so turns
out that in the CF our family c FR plus
has for a few years now been basically
unbeatable and a lot of people have
tried to come up with new variants of
the CF our family and they've all been
either way slower than c FR plus or a
little bit slower and but now we have
something as faster as we're planning to
submit in within a month then regret
decomposition framework I mentioned that
in CFR you are actually decomposing the
regret so that you can do regret
minimization separately in the
information sets but in South that the
way to do it in CFR is not the only way
there's actually this infinite family of
exact decompositions you can do and now
you can go beyond the CFR family and
again there you can get better
algorithms than in the CFR framework
then equilibrium finding algorithms by
developing new theory of gradient based
techniques so gradient based techniques
have better worst-case convergence rates
and CFR by
a lot but in practice CFR has been
faster it's kind of a mystery and it's
still kind of true but now we're within
a factor of four of CFR speed with these
types of algorithms as well
Algrim spore equilibrium refinements we
talked about mostly Nash equilibrium
today but Nash equilibrium doesn't play
optimally if the opponent or we have
made a mistake in the game so far and
that's where equilibrium refinements
come in they're basically additional
constraints on what counts as a good
solution and just to pick one here this
last one trembling hand refinements are
maybe the most famous family of those
and they have been very unfair to
compute even for tiny games and
numerically in stable unstable so now we
have algorithms that compute trembling
hand refinements for games with about
ten thousand maybe thirty thousand notes
so still weigh less callable but several
orders of magnitude more scalable than
before equilibrium fighting algorithms
for two agents that's still way less
scalable we have the fastest one
currently for normal formal games so
matrix form games and how it works is
that we're doing three search not in the
space of the discrete supports of the
actions as to what actions are in play
like we and others have tried before but
in the space of the continuous
probabilities so we basically split the
probability space into these hyper
rectangles and then we have an Oracle
which checks where the hyper rectangle
can potentially have an equilibrium in
it in this nonlinear problem of more
than two agents and then exploration
exploitation versus exploit ability I've
had this on this slide for in my thought
for a long time now and we still haven't
really cracked it but I can say a few
interesting things about it so in
reinforcement learning there is
trade-off between exploration and
exploitation in games there's also this
third dimension of exploit ability as I
start to exploit how much
do I open myself up to exploitation and
the folk wisdom had been that if I
exploit more than any game theoretic
strategy would in a Nash equilibrium
strategy would then I'm opening myself
to exploitation turns out not true you
can actually completely safely exploit
your opponent by more than that up to a
pound which we characterize and it's
actually has a nice intuition in that I
can't really well let me say what
doesn't work first so you might think
that I can take the winnings that I have
from Eric so far and I can bankroll my
exploitation I can exploit him so much
that I might lose up to what I've
already won it seems like that might be
safe but it's not safe because I'm
walking with my upside and my downside
from an ex ante perspective is still all
there so I need to be able to separate
out what I have won based on luck versus
Eric's mistakes and if I can lower bound
how much I've won based on Eric's
mistakes that is the amount that I can
use to bankroll my exploitation in the
future and then final thing on this
slide is depth limited solving in
imperfect information games so we talked
about sub game solving but that was
solving the end of the game now we can
actually solve the beginning and the
middle as well on the fly the idea that
doesn't work here is to say I'm gonna
fix the opponent's strategy at the leaf
to what they will play in the blueprint
because that gives me too much power
instead I'm gonna give the opponent one
final action at each leaf it's each leaf
information set and there they can
choose which strategy to play and that
takes away that extra power and that is
the idea based on which we can do depth
limited solving in imperfect information
games and this has theoretical
guarantees and this created the boat
Morecambe in my lab which was created on
one server and to our knowledge it's the
second best AI for this problem
alright so commercial applications well
I think that more
real-world settings are imperfect
information games although they're not
treated as such and now that we have
this type of technology I think we're
going to start to see applications where
things are really treated as games for
what they are so one example is
strategic pricing typically when
companies do pricing they optimize their
prices given their competitors price is
fixed single agent problem but in
reality of course the competitors change
the prices and you don't want to be just
pre optimizing to that and being
reactive you want to think about these
things ahead same in strategic product
portfolio optimization gaming video
games training streams you can make
really exciting streams by having this
superhuman areas play against each other
boat detection turns out that they have
moves that he must never play and there
are millions of them and you can eat you
can detect pots not just by looking at
the operating system level but really
from the strategies themselves automated
negotiation electricity markets various
aspects of site finance investment
banking political campaigns how do you
spend media against an adversary
business strategy hey wouldn't it be
nice if there were actually some
strategy in business strategy bidding
how do you bid for example for oil
tracts and then once you know how to bid
you can actually evaluate auction
designs that you couldn't normally
evaluate because you can't solve for
equilibrium strategic market
segmentation same thing is with pricing
typically market segmentation has been
treated as a static problem of course
you have to think about strategically
how would the competitors change their
strategies in the views change their
segmentation in the future interaction
between vehicles and autonomous filetes
so let's say that you have two operators
of autonomous fleets in the future the
rules of the road put limits on what
they can do but there are a lot of
unspecified things like how do we merge
for example wouldn't it be nice if we
wouldn't have to negotiate those in some
ad hoc way on the fly but there are too
many negotiation situations to manually
negotiate in advance so you would want
to somehow automate that acquisition
strategies like movie rights
how should streaming companies buy
movies
which movie should they bid for in what
order should they buy them from the
movie studios what should they offer and
so on sports of course lots of sports
applications and maybe the most radical
it's kind of a long story but steering
evolution and biological adaptation
strategically for example for medical
treatment planning or synthetic biology
and then there's a bunch of government
applications so if you think about it
traditionally in military planning
whether it's cyber security or actual
physical military or whatever you assume
a naive opponent and naive read a fake
strategy you assign a strategy and then
you simulate against that or do war
gaming against that here
unlike simulation ready strategy is not
input by this rather output so you're
actually looking at all of the possible
opponent strategies and so your robust
and that there's a bunch of applications
thank you very much
[Applause]
you wouldn't need your sub-game
innovations to do approximately good job
to those open world mouths messy spaces
it seems the forest in generically
looking at game theoretic approaches in
these spaces what do you have you seen
actual application of the nuances of the
way you solve the two-player yeah so
it's useful an open world yeah so um
there's always a question of modeling
and when we think about business
strategy for these two startups we're
looking at what are the closest where we
can say it okay well we have pretty good
models you start from there good models
and close to zero sum or exactly zero
sum so you're really looking at very
adversarial situations high stakes of
course and once where the Rumsfeld a and
unknown unknowns are not that they can
make a deal but no modeling is really I
would say the number one bottleneck here
is that if the real world is such that
you can't really model it accurately
that is the number one source topper now
I'm not sure there's this infinitely
many real world applications and pulley
infinitely many that you can model so
while it's a very I'm not really worried
and the other is the abstraction
techniques and now if you can bound the
difference between the real world and
the model you can say that hey even if
you solve just the model you were close
to optimal for thorium okay yeah so you
know part of the game theory approaches
the idea that even if your opponent
notice your policy right dude no it
wouldn't change anything
wait have you tried this with the humans
in the sense that if you have a
probability over a range of hands then
you can actually expose that to the
humans because I still don't know what
action you took and actually start
reflecting the internal state of the bot
to them right so the Bob would actually
say here's the hands I put you on that's
effectively a summary of the policy from
the point of view of them they don't
know what you know what action you took
after that have you tried seeing that
and see how they adapt or learn based on
that no but we've done
something similar and Eric and I were
chatting a little bit about this on the
fireside chat so again this comes to
people believing in people so we got
into in the poker already before this
event for the last few years before that
the last couple at least into a
situation where when human expert poker
players would tell us that okay they
report there is a bot made a mistake
chances were much higher that they were
wrong then that the board had made a
mistake and what we did
I had Chris Ferguson who served really
kind of a mathematical PhD level guy
who's a top poker player look at these
situations where somebody told us that
hey that was a mistake
then we would give him the belief
distributions and the path and
everything and he would actually write
these little essays as to what happened
and every time you know the it was like
superhuman reasoning in his words you
know it was thinking like two levels
deeper than any human and at once he had
three days to think about it he was
actually that was a brilliant move not a
mistake but but sometimes they look
weird like I have one one happened
during the play we had the AI called I
think maybe it was an all in or some
other huge huge pot called a huge bit
with Jack hi and most people who play
poker would said okay well that was a
mistake but turns out that exactly with
that Jack and that other card maybe it
was a three or whatever that is exactly
with what you do you play the light call
just to that because you have to light
call with something and with the
blockers you know that was exactly the
hand to do the light call with and you
don't do it with a hundred percent you
do it for some percent and which was not
near zero but the you know once he
really thought that through he actually
saw the merit in that
machine learning listen like you know
you've talked about alcohol and almost
materials like you know the setup it
means that went into that right and now
you have like you have this really good
like you know poker players is there any
like you know but does it help you for
example like you know in addition to
that like you're solving it in a very
strong manner but does it helping
compute like you know maybe like the
first part we're doing the abstraction
engineers many months or many thousand
CPU cycles who who've tried would like
to learn from export demonstrations and
then doing the compute upwards such
seeded by that but is that not still a
viable strategy I see at least three
three roles one is that we now have the
reef warm starts techniques so you can
actually warm start from any strategy no
matter how its computed whether it's
computed with machine learning or some
guy just thought that that was a good
idea it doesn't matter we can warm start
from that the second is that when we do
opponent exploitation those techniques
which we didn't use here but those
techniques you could think of those as
machine learning techniques which are
kind of fortified by game theoretic
reasoning and and there there's
definitely a role for machine learning
and data and then the third is the
modeling so I have to believe that
machine learning which is all backward
looking and strategic reasoning which is
all forward-looking they have to be
somehow synergistic and one of the ways
that those are synergistic I think is
that machine learning can be used to
learn the model or aspects of the model
but for example chance probabilities
which are not strategic or what moves
are possible things like that
you try to bring the system yet in a
tournament where you know early rounds
of tournaments are all about
exploitation so that you can chip up and
then have the chip advantage how does it
actually perform and sort of multi
player situations yeah we haven't really
played tournaments and we haven't played
multiplayer we have a couple of players
but pay early papers a long time ago on
three-player jump all tournaments like
three player in games of tournaments but
we haven't really looked at the
tournament play per se one thing I can
say is that when it comes to no
tournaments but multiplayer I hear from
a lot of boaters not academics but
boaters that the way they generate the
top boats today for like say six max
they're very much the same techniques so
while there's in theory there's this big
complexity gap between two player
zero-sum games and more general games in
practice at least for poker it seems
that the same techniques do well even a
even in those more general settings over
some abstraction but it's Nash right
approximate Nash for some abstraction
here and so even in that I guess for any
coarse or fine abstraction at least in
poker it seems once you have a good
model the right move is kind of I
wouldn't say immediate but at least
computable right you could say this is a
right move distribution by I guess in
real life even if I know the right move
is to exit the room it takes a lot of
actuator to actually affect that goal
right so like I guess in there are there
are settings where you have to go but it
takes some extra mileage to actually
reach that goal right and I think you
progress more in media I need to make
this move and you could directly affect
that move forever
I think how do you reason about that
where even if the mode of the world is
taken to reach them go there needs to be
some kind of planning we're learning how
to actually perform the action that do
it right it's kind of like I know the
best thing to do is if I take my 3-point
shot here but I can't do it because I
cannot make the shot board like how do
you reason about this yeah well we don't
yeah you're right we don't well when we
take an AK it's not like robotics where
there's slippage and whatever it's it's
it's like when we take an action that
action happens but I'll take issue with
the first part which is that somehow
when you get the abstraction it's
somehow immediate what the probabilities
should be that's very hard to compute
with algorithms that have been
developed over 14 15 years on a
supercomputer for months so it's not
immediate its computable right so is
there I mean there will be cases where
these days no matter how much you
compute this not computable right like
how do you how do you reason about that
yeah we I'm personally not that
interesting in that question but I can
tell you some things that people have
done so there's for example game
theoretic strategies under execution
uncertainty there are a few papers on
that for example for billiards but not
not from Michael
[Applause]